Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
almost back to school time and that will
mean parents have to worry about school
immunization so we get more information
from Southwest Medical the sponsors of
this segment
PA Sandusky welcome back to Las Vegas
now
thanks for having me good to see you and
I just I know you just told me your your
kid is at home it's summertime
um you guys are having some fun some
quality time but we have to remember
School vaccinations are required as
they're headed back to school
yeah and believe it or not we're already
halfway through summer so school's going
to be here before you know it
now um
missions and just you know what people
should know going in
so especially with school being an
environment where there's close
proximity between children adolescents
that increases risk of disease
transmission so making sure that our
kids are up to date with their routine
immunizations as well as their checkups
is super important before they start the
school year statistics show that 4
million deaths worldwide are prevented
with immunizations wow and what are the
best types of protection for the kids
so we rely on what's called Community
immunity or herd immunity and this is
where when the majority of the
population is vaccinated it's more
difficult for a disease to infect people
because there are less that they are
able to infect since the majority of the
population have those disease fighting
antibodies
and I know one of the sayings is also
don't wait to vaccinate you know what's
the age requirement for the kids to be
immunized
yeah so there's a slew of immunizations
from birth to you know adulthood right
so for schools specifically there are
required vaccinations for kindergarten
the measles mumps rubella varicella
DTaP ipv for seventh grade the Tdap and
the meningitis are required and new as
of 2022 last school year for 12th grade
the meningitis is required and I know
Southwest Medical is hosting a back to
school fair for our schools here in
Clark County um can you tell us about
that and what people can expect I know
they'll be able to learn about all these
vaccinations and requirements
yeah your pediatricians are your best
source of information in regards to your
child's care so we are hosting our
annual back to school Fair Saturday July
22nd from 8 A.M to 2 p.m at our Oakey
healthcare clinic and in addition to
that Southwest Medical does have seven
pediatric locations around town we do
offer a Saturday Clinic as well as
extended hour clinic actually three of
them three of our clinics have extended
hours during the week to increase access
to care we want to get these kids in for
their routine checkups Vision hearing
screening sports physicals and sooner
rather than later with the back to
school Rush about to happen
oh okay are you ready for that
not quite sure but we're there and let's
get these kids in before you know August
7th is the first day of school for CCSD
and it'll be here before we know it
we want to thank Southwest Medical for
being one of our Community Pride
Partners now I'm sure immunizations were
not your favorite thing going back to
school but what was your favorite what
did you look forward to I look forward
to the school supplies getting a new
backpack you're probably too young for
this but the Trapper Keeper
oh my gosh
they're the coolest things ever mine was
a Transformer one keeper the traffic in
the lunch box too oh my gosh my little
special lunchbox I had a thing for Pins
pens pins and pencils I was very serious
about that I know what you get your free
birthday we'll be right back